herr präsident meine damen und herren
wer nicht weiß das programm karl bauer
in der cdu ist wer nicht weiß dass
angela merkel bundeskanzlerin ist und
wer nicht weiß dass die spd in dieser
regierung steckt wobei dies tatsächlich
leicht zu übersehen ist der könnte jetzt
denken donnerwetter ab morgen wird die
bundeswehr wieder auf die beine gestellt
herrliche zeiten brechen an öffentliche
gelöbnisse an zwölfter november in den
bundesländern und vor dem reichstag
aber diese ankündigung sorry steht die
unverrückbare realität der ära merkel
gegenüber und die besteht aus vor allem
aus moderieren und aussetzen
noch vorige woche sagte die
bundeskanzlerin über die neue ministerin
ich freue mich dass annegret kramp
karrenbauer sich entschieden hat
verteidigungsministerin zu werden und
sie wird es sehr gut machen nach meiner
festen überzeugung zutaten
[Applaus]
darauf hatte ich jetzt endlich mal
gehofft ich hab's erreicht was frau
bundeskanzlerin
[Applaus]
was frau bundeskanzlerin überzeugt sie
eigentlich jedes mal aufs neue das
völlig fachfremde personal fernab jeder
affinität zu streitkräften die
bundeswehr gut führen kann
die bundeswehr ist heute in der
schlechtesten verfassung seit ihrer
ausstellung in 1955
diese erschreckende diagnose galt auch
schon vor fünf jahren
seitdem hat sich substanziell nichts
verbessert vieles ist aber weiter bergab
gegangen
schiffe panzer und flugzeuge sind nicht
einsatzbereit die motorrad die moral der
truppe ist am boden
gender unfug und aufgeweichte standards
in der ausbildung haben das innere
gefüge unserer streitkräfte zersetzt
ein hand
ein handfester betrugs stand
betrugsskandal bei auftragsvergabe und
das segelschulschiff gorch fock ein
günstling skandal um den illegalen
einsatz von beratern der
sicherheitspolitische umfeld europas ist
angespannt wie seit 30 jahren nicht
und was macht die cdu geführte
bundesregierung sie begeht
verfassungsbruch artikel 87a der bund
stellt streitkräfte zur verteidigung auf
unsere streitkräfte sind zur
landesverteidigung nicht befähigt in
dieser äußerst in dieser äußerst
kritischen situation setzt die tun cdu
eine sicherheitspolitische novizen aus
dem saarland als verteidigungsministerin
ein
eine frau
eine frau die über einen deutsch
französischen flugzeugträger formuliert
eine frau die über deutsche bodentruppen
in syrien nachdenkt meine damen und
herren
die cdu ist zum größten risiko für die
deutsche sicherheitspolitik geworden
[Applaus]
juni unbenutzt das
verteidigungsministerium ministerium
seit 14 jahren als steinbruch um ihren
machterhalt zu sichern
die cdu sieht das amt des
verteidigungsministers als trainee
stelle und provinzen familienpolitikerin
ganz wörtlich zu machen und die
um die einsatzbereitschaft der
bundeswehr oder um die soldaten selbst
geht es der union schon lange nicht mehr
wie die cdu mit der sicherheit
deutschlands umgeht ist skandalös
es ist schlimmer als das es ist
unpatriotisch
[Applaus]
um die sicherheit um die sicherheit
deutschlands schützen zu können brauchen
wir eine bundeswehr die zur landes- und
bündnisverteidigung befähigt ist
das ist ihr grund gesetzlicher auftrag
unsere soldaten leisten ihren eid darauf
damit unsere soldaten diesen auch
erfüllen können brauchen sie materielle
volle ausstattung die großen
beschaffungsvorhaben ist zügig auf den
weg gebracht werden
die bundeswehr braucht auch die personal
personelle vollausstattung um ihren
auftrag erfüllen zu können
der fünfjährige versuch mit
werbekampagnen mit youtube filmchen
girls days und hat nicht dazu geführt
gute und genügend rekruten zu gewinnen
genau wie die dazugehörige ministerin
2000 20.000 stellen sind nicht besetzt
deutschland braucht die wehrpflicht
zurück
[Applaus]
[Musik]
frau kramp karrenbauer sprach sich im
sommer sehr energisch für eine
allgemeine dienstpflicht aus
die soll in ihrer vorstellung ja auch
die wehrpflicht enthalten ich nehme also
an frau ministerin dass sie bereits die
weisung erteilt haben die
wiedereinsetzung der wehrpflicht in
ihrem hause zu prüfen
ich nehme auch an dass sie bereits
weisung erteilt haben die investitionen
der bundeswehr im hinblick auf 1,5
prozent bis 2024 und das zwei prozent
ziel darüber hinaus zu planen was unsere
bundeswehr vordringlich braucht kostet
zunächst nicht viel geld
unsere bundeswehr braucht eine
geistig-moralische neuaufstellung
gradlinigkeit
gradlinigkeit ehrlichkeit und der wille
dem deutschen volk zu dienen sind
unabdingbare voraussetzungen für gute
soldaten und eine schlagkräftige armee
mit der befähigung zum kampf wie aber
kann man von seinen soldaten dies alles
verlangen wenn sich die politische
leitung nicht daran hält bei dem
gelöbnis am letzten samstag sagte die
neue ministerin den 400 angetretenen
rekruten rekruten sie können sich auf
mich verlassen noch vor zwei wochen
allerdings sagte die neue ministerin
auch gar nicht ministerin werden zu
wollen
und heute wurden sie hier vereidigt ist
das die art verlässlichkeit die sie
meinen mit ihrer art politik zu machen
schädigt die bundesregierung nachhaltig
das vertrauen der bevölkerung unter uns
in start
die bundeskanzlerin ist ihr installiert
ihre sogenannten kronprinzessinnen nach
feudaler art bahn ergebnisse werden
ignoriert das vergebene wort hat keinen
wert es geht um macht und um macht
allein auf dem rücken unserer soldaten
und unser aller sicherheit und die
verteidigungspolitiker der cdu tragen
dieses alles mit im ausschuss mühen sie
sich nach kräften ab um das konservative
gesicht der cdu zu halten aber im
entscheidenden moment geben sie kampflos
auf und lassen sich zu staffage
degradieren die nachfolgeregelung der
bundeskanzlerin ist in der cdu wichtiger
als fachkompetenz und der dienst für uns
erfolgt ehrlich gesagt tun sie mir leid
der neuen ministerin ist bereits viel
glück für amt gewünscht wurden
vollkommen falsch unsere bundeswehr
ordentlich zu führen ist nämlich keine
glückssache sondern eine frage der
sachverstand und des herzens lassen war
das der verteidigungspolitische sprecher
der ard
die cdu
ein anderes größeres sicherheitsrisiko
für deutschland und forderte dass die
affichen häufiger gefordert hat die
rückkehr der wehrpflicht